[Music]
Wednesday night we got [__] stars we
got this [__] that's beautiful
[Music]
[Laughter]
everybody oh [__]
if it takes all night
[Music]
everybody wants to take a chance
everybody wants to do this terribly want
to do that
[Music]
oh [__]
we're gonna get that type of cloud at
that Starbucks one of your [__] friends
with a vapor pad [__] uncle Joey blows
these when I have the [__] mule of
death and don't let me get the savage
look at him he says he doesn't need
nobody's [__] in a month look at this
[__] guy look at that eye he has to
eat nobody's ass on a month clearly
looks like a cat's eye at 1:00 in the
morning you understand me [__] around
too late [__] easier in a yacht
the church has changed the new name of
the podcast is three Jews with Vaseline
on their fingers
that's the Jews I'm hanging out with
from now on people with gasoline on
their fingers I don't hang out with you
Gentiles no more if you're not a Jew
with a bottle of Vaseline your pocket
hang up now I don't wanna hang out with
you no more
they could stick it up your ass and say
not only I wanna hang out with Jews or
gonna stick it up your ass that's it
it's all over we [__] around them I
got a lawyer that's missing two arms
he's angry I'm sayin another Jew he
can't got money in our first Freddie is
he's got a [__] counter with his nose
that's the kind of Jew you want in your
corner a little advice from the Cuban
and I'm saying besides that it's gonna
be a good night [__] one two
three and you thought it was gonna be an
easy night you [__] tonight please tell
you why it's not even to come home that
you live in our clothes tonight
[Laughter]
[Music]
look down the hatch
you got two more to go cut tell us what
you go to diner mama there must be some
place you can go oh [__] in the middle
it's all drinks and the drama and they
like these bags are getting light dawg
almost now look you're looking good
enough cuz you're so smooth in the world
zone run are you kidding me you're so
smooth and the world's so rough
you just don't write that type of [__]
you got to do 92 shots a heroin yep
jesus christ almighty you know what this
guy used to do they wrote a book in this
town in 1997 called you'll never work in
this town again
and it was about a hooker who wrote a
book and this guy had a whole chapter on
on Don Henley he would call five [__]
make him call to his house snort coke
take their clothes off then they just
bend them over backwards and he just sit
there that's not coke and look at that
pussy's from behind and then they'd be
wants a how he go up and just stick
another [__] two or three times and he
sit back down again and the girls would
go can we get a line [__] no and he
would just sit there no coke get
evil-looking all that [__] is [__]
that's the life I'm saying
you two can achieve those goals
it's time for Bonaduce we get on those
[__] stars huh
forget it that's how you write music
that's the only one that's the only way
you write music this way is if you did
90 shots ahem I think music too late
sucks nobody wants to do heroin yes why
do you think they're doing all the
movies and TV shows from the eighties
nobody wants to do everyone if you did
having this creativity booing let's have
one that comes from [__] Afghanistan
process the best by Chinese people why
did the Chinese people good at math
again I didn't know that now you know
[__] know but they do that China
white and I [__] I do two shots at China
friend why I could do trigonometry how
you do trig like nothing like you join
where you've been all these years
doing trig [__] enough is enough it's
time to do some bondage to Jerry's kids
and for Jerry I'm saying out of respect
for Jerry Jerry ain't doing so well
right now we got the kid look at this
little lighter Jennifer Jones made me
[__] beautiful I love Janica the
husband she's a real artiste not a sack
of [__] like myself
[Music]
[Laughter]
waiting a class like that cue Melinda's
Nimbus by bimba's you ain't never seen a
clown like that [__] you don't
even know what that cloud gives you
[__] start eating stars [__] I
got the next bomb up I don't want to I
want to see them but this is the arm
liad what's his name this is the Eagles
last out they said we can't do it no
more
we can't stand [__] the guitar player
this is the long run are you [__]
kidding me
how do you write this music heroin
you're not doing heroin it's not gonna
work out for you oh [__] I just say no
I'm just saying you're sitting there
like a bump of the log with a [__]
feather in your hand thinking about what
you're gonna write next
and you've never read nothin it's time
to do everyone yet I'm saying
and that's it you ready how many numbers
is that remember the breathing exercises
not your chest but your stomach make
sure that [__] bellybutton it's your
spine
this is bong hit camp 101 [__]
this is a free trial after this you got
y'all you look up let the blood hit the
back he add think about the technique
and what you're about to do pick up the
bonds we don't be this is how you do it
Bartman oh [__] this is the one that
killed [__] Sharon Tate
[Music]
don't we there you go that's the one
that's the one
[Music]
tip-top Magoo yeah I'm saying that
nobody's feeling bad in the more they
couples bond that's never killed nobody
[Music]
perfect that's what he has for your life
you don't need those you don't say that
you're 29 you're moving to the next step
of your life oh you bad [__]
and you thought it was gonna be a boring
night you gonna watch Empire I gotta
tell you what I did I went to 7-Eleven
to get some nicotine gum but I was
behind this black dude buying beer and
[__] Snickers ice cream and he kept
looking at the wings right and he goes
yo brother how much for the wings they
goes six wings for five hours
he went over inspected the wings and I
whispered to him I said dog you don't
want to eat those ices wings I know you
eat those wings will set brothers back
two thousand [__] years he just
looked at me and goes you're right and
they told the guy they shoved those
wings up his ass
he knows [__] Isis wings from
7-eleven these [__] Isis are
try anyway to kill you dog said 11 wings
don't do none that some 11 the taquitos
the [__] Oscar Meyer that's Oscar
[__] Isis that [__] writes of
that [__] pizza don't do nothing at
7-eleven I don't care what the [__] they
value I don't give a [__] if it's the
last meal in America then the [__]
Lindsey Joe Walsh and I sell them
are you [__] kidding me anybody know
they don't have time they were too busy
snorting coke and shooting H here we go
oh [__] oh [__]
I think the name of this song is the
Greeks don't want no freaks watch
[Music]
there you go the Greeks don't know who
the [__] do you think you're dealing
with me I haven't heard this album in 10
years
marijuana is good for the mind
understand me forget all fibers you know
what all slime and smoke some weed late
you ready for two more stars it's time
for another bombing
believe it or not I don't know if you're
gonna do one but I'm doing one on my own
[__]
the rest is up to you it's Thursday
everybody wants to get the weekend
started this is how it starts your uncle
Joey
[Music]
the Greeks don't want those freaks you
[__] malakas
[Music]
the Greeks don't want no grief
lick lick pizza - no next pizza [__] you
[__] speak
there's another bonding captain [__] you
you two listen I'm gonna do a quick
registration for Banga camp next summer
three-week [__] and then when you
come back we take it to the mouth that's
the next summer look back three let the
belly button hit the spine prepared
along right let's do this [__] supposed
to see it snuck up on you let's do this
the Greeks the one that'll just be a
bond next to them they have to take a
bond sure let's go [__] smoke the
joint we there's a beautiful blend of
aromatic reefers oh [__] you think
you're dealing with
listen I'm being a MOOC all your life
going to parties nobody talks who blows
shotguns like that you have a thousand
people around you rubbing your back
rubbing your toes your face is already
and say mean and uglies doing with a dog
I'm saying anyway we're gonna start this
thing in about five minutes go to
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz
[Music]
sale the winner that [__] I'm saying
wave flopping around you want to [__]
around go hang out with these other
[__] fake pot smokers uncle Joey is
the last of the real [__] deal I want
to drink I don't want to talk to you
about trauma I don't want to talk to you
about nothing you want to smoke weed you
come over here you want talking about
nonsense stay in your house I got it mom
I'm saying I don't need your [__]
hippie tea anyway go to youtube.com
slash a slash Joey Diaz and don't forget
this is it this week and the party
starts tomorrow night and that's why
this periscope is brought to you by my
bookie dot neck right is it my bookie
bat Messer
my bookie dotnet go down there and tell
him Joey said [__] and they're gonna
hook you up you never bet this weekend
anyway what is it my bookie dot AG
that's the way to beat don't tell him
uncle Joey said you want to code put in
code Church and what do they do they're
gonna match your [__] deposits up to
$1,000 if I was your I get my ass over
there right now my bookie eg AG AG agent
there's an apple G as in giant during
you know how we [__] do it
[__] anyway
ten minutes youtube.com / c / Joey Diaz
thank you for joining us and listening
to a phenomenal how though the long run
by the Eagles in the fun My Mind's going
I got a lot of things on my mind
nice thing